on March 5th 2022 Russian gymnast Yvonne
kuliak stepped on the podium at the
International Gymnastics Federation
World Cup in Doha Qatar he won the
bronze medal in the parallel bars next
to him was Elia kufton the Gold Medal
winner from Ukraine and silver medalist
Milad Karimi representing Kazakhstan the
situation was already tense Russia's
invasion of Ukraine had begun just nine
days earlier and kuliak decided to show
his support for the war by attaching
this symbol to his uniform three pieces
of white tape forming the letter Z by
that time the Z was becoming an
obsession in Russia and a controversial
symbol worldwide as the new way to
Signal approval for the war and loyalty
to Russian President Vladimir Putin
since the invasion began in late
February the Z has shown up on
billboards in St Petersburg t-shirt
stands in Moscow Auto rallies and flash
mobs created for social media
there's even this photo posted on the
website of a children's cancer hospice
showing sick children organized into the
shape outside in the snow the letter has
been used to vandalize the homes of
Russians who opposed the war and is now
banned from public display in several
countries so how did this symbol become
shorthand for supporting Russian
aggression
the letter Z was first spotted in late
February 2022 on Russian military
equipment gathering at Ukraine's border
along with other painted White markings
like V and O
at first what these symbols meant was
unclear Z isn't part of the Cyrillic
alphabet the writing system used in
Russia and Ukraine the z sound in
Cyrillic is written sort of like a three
and V looks like the Latin letter B but
once the invasion began most analysts
agreed the markings were for tactical
purposes likely to prevent confusion on
the battlefield and potentially denoting
where specific forces were attacking
from the Russian military didn't explain
what the markings meant until Intrigue
around them grew online and people in
Russia saw the chance to use the Z as a
tool for propaganda one of the most
common ways the letter Z is being given
meaning in Russian is by latinizing it
in the Russian word za which means for
and incorporating it into slogans like
the president
so there was an attempt to fill it
that's a glass netcov she's a lecturer
on Russian foreign security and domestic
policy at University College London you
increasingly have pictures which are so
absurdly staged it's obviously fake but
it sort of doesn't matter so the
pictures of the kids for example who
like can't even read and write they
obviously have no idea what the Zed
they're holding means or anything like
that but it sort of Almost Doesn't
Matter so long as you throw it out there
click on these slogans hashtags like for
Russia and four peace and you'll find
tens of thousands of posts on Instagram
alone many of them originating from the
Russian Ministry of Defense the
political technologists in Russia in
Kremlin and in and around the ministry
of Defense have decided to jump on the
opportunity and reinfuse the meaning of
those obscure symbols kiril avramov
teaches classes on Russian and Soviet
symbolism and propaganda at the
University of Texas Austin avramov told
me the point of these memes is to turn
the Z and sometimes the V into something
cool he translated a few of them so
patanov is like a street slang for for
the boys and says
power is in truth which is actually a
quote from a post-soviet blockbuster the
Seal of gravity they're picking already
familiar slogans to possoviet Russians
and putting into those visuals and then
recreating those in flash mobs graffiti
and all the way to the presidential
Administration
one strategy for turning Z into a
patriotic propaganda icon has been
connecting it to Russian glory of the
past in particular the Soviet victory in
World War II the Soviet Union suffered
devastating losses defending itself
against Invasion by Nazi Germany but
they were ultimately Victorious with the
red army fighting its way back to Berlin
and defeating Hitler establishing the
Soviet Union as a world superpower the
Great Patriotic War is still a potent
symbol of heroism and glory in Russia
and is honored each year on May 9th or
Victory Day the anniversary of Germany's
capitulation with massive demonstrations
of modern military might and remembrance
of ancestors who were killed in the war
the historical trauma is immense in
Soviet times it was a huge sacrifice on
the part of the Soviet people and those
are some highly symbolic events this
ever-present historical awareness makes
World War to imagery a direct link to
patriotism and presents the opportunity
to connect the Nostalgia of Soviet
heroism with Russia's current attacks on
Ukraine
take this meme posted to the Russian
Ministry of defense's Instagram on March
4th 2022 which as of early April has
over 21 000 likes it shows a z
superimposed over a black and white
photo of Soviet soldiers on one side and
a photo of modern Russian soldiers
looking back on the other side the
hashtag says Heroes the photo on the
left is a famous image from the original
Moscow Victory Parade of 1945
celebrating Germany's surrender it's
still the largest Parade ever held in
moscow's Red Square organized by Soviet
dictator Joseph Stalin the image shows
Soviet soldiers carrying captured Nazi
flags and Banners before destroying them
and has been used in Soviet and
post-soviet patriotic propaganda ever
since so every Russian person would
recognize that immediately
the Z is paired with a slogan Za papiero
for victory and is styled in black and
orange stripes which other than plain
white is the most common way the Z is
displayed the pattern represents the
color scheme of the ribbon of Saint
George one of Putin's favorite
propaganda symbols its Origins Trace
back through hundreds of years of
Russian history as a symbol of military
Glory at the end of World War II Stalin
used the ribbon on a medal awarded to
all Soviets who served in the war
including civilians the ribbon which
everyone knows is you know if you see it
it's the Russian military might and it's
a signifier that you're Russian the
ribbon of Saint George is now handed out
every year ahead of Victory Day and is a
central emblem of the celebrations
invoking the memory of the Glorious past
in order to play this propaganda trick
right equating this war with this one in
terms of justness and legitimacy
Beyond emerging as the new mark of
loyalty to Putin the Z doesn't hold any
individual meaning and that seems to be
part of the strategy behind it and that
I think shows the way in which
Christians propaganda sort of works he
throws things out there sees What lands
and then goes for that the symbol just
became recognizable the explanations
which I call post-rationalization is
that this is all planned you know
disease and the V stand for victory for
zelenski for you name it the advancement
of so many alternative explanations adds
energy to their state propaganda whether
or not any of these explanations end up
sticking disease Evolution from tanks
and trucks to memes then flash mobs
around Russia to pro-putin
demonstrations Around the World shows
that as a symbol's visibility grows so
does its power as a tool for propaganda
foreign
[Music]